mark in your book the film directors bag
of tricks I think I noticed that you
wrote something about director Elia
Kazan and how he would get to know
actors and take them out to dinner and
really find out about their story have
you done that with actors do you feel
that it's very crucial in terms of
getting the most from that character you
know and finding out what lenses they're
seeing everything what assumptions yeah
I think yeah I think you're getting to
know the actors is crucial like there
are a lot of maybe not a lot and for
several directors who even say they
don't need to lead the actors they just
need to meet them and get to know them
before they cast but I think like what
the Lee because then we do a lot of
directors do again coming out of theater
these are people commodity we get to
know the actors personally remember when
you're casting and somebody an actor
comes in and reads for you and let's say
he just reads one scene all you know at
that moment is how well he can read that
scene that's all you know
now maybe did it beautifully maybe it
was very impressive but you know nothing
beyond that and what one of the things
you don't know you don't know anything
about him or her so this is someone
you're considering casting yes get to
know them some directors I've worked
with early even invite three or four
actors back for call back and never read
them we just sit around and talk with
them and discuss things and just to get
to know that the personality you got to
get to know who these people are how
they think
remember if you cast them you're going
to spend a long time with them and
you're not spending a long time with
them just reading that part you're
spending a long time with that person
and you need to establish a relationship
with them how you can work with them how
they think what they believe in and
important part of say taking an actor to
lunch or something they need to get to
know you you need to be just as open and
available and vulnerable to them as you
want them to be to you because then
you're creating a safe space for within
they can work they need to know that you
are there and you are willing to become
as vulnerable and it's open and as
available as they are as you want them
to be okay so let's say you've you've
met the factor you've had coffee with
them whatever you've had them read
they're great for the part then they
show up on set and they're not as open
they're a little more closed off okay I
have a question for you sure between
meeting them and casting them and then
you jump to now they show up on the set
why has it been any rehearsal in between
sure there's been rehearsal I think
maybe during rehearsal they were good
and you felt that they they brought what
the character needed but then they show
up on set and they're closed off okay
let's assume that's been rehearsal which
we haven't talked about yet but there's
been rehearsal and interrogation adds
and we're in good shape
now we go to they show up in the set and
they're closed off and my job very very
important job at this point is to unjust
try to understand why and I can tell you
right now why generally why the actors
closed off something's wrong something
they're afraid of fear it's usually a
fear-based something is in the way now
it can be some actors just get closed
off because we're shifting into
production like we talked about before
that shift it could be fear of making
usually fear I'm not going to do a job
I'm going to make a mistake something's
going to go wrong and so they they will
retreat within themselves
this is very normal it's very natural
it's nothing to be worried about but it
is something to be dealt with you have
to deal with it and I can tell you the
best way to deal with it is to actually
ignore it because if you start talking
about it you can own but very possibly
make it worse what are you afraid of oh
it's just a camera turn you know you're
talking about the fear and it'll just
get bigger that's all you have to do the
best way to deal with it is ignore it
honor it but ignore
and go into the interrogation process if
I start shifting with that actor and
start talking to the character you know
what happens to that fear it goes into
the background with the actor as I
allowed the actor to shift into the
background and pull the character into
the foreground okay
the fear that the actor has goes with
the actor doesn't stay with the
character the actor will probably feel
very comfortable just being the
character you don't want the actor to
drag that fear or whatever the concern
is into the character that's what you
have to avoid and through the
interrogation process you can actually
stop it before that happens you know you
would talk in your video about sometimes
when you push up against something for
so long it becomes this obstacle that
you can't defeat now for awhile and
maybe I'm butchering what you said but I
find that fascinating concepts so it can
you talk about how that happens and in
just a metaphorical sense well yeah I
mean yeah in that video talking about
pushing up against an obstacle something
that's resisting you up and I believe
what you're referring to is I'm talking
about a character doing that not so much
an actor or a director but a character
doing that which is pretty much the same
thing as an actor or director and then
what we do what all of us will do it for
pushing up against something and there
seems to be no way to get around it and
we can't make any progress we will do
what I call an adjustment we will shift
from where we are and try to pursue the
same objective from a different angle
which is in other words change our
attitude change our modus operandi
change our plans right somebody wants to
be an actor rate wants me I can't get
any work can't can they work and say
okay I'll move to New York there's an
adjustment it may or may not work I
don't know but we will make an
adjustment to get around it now this
discussion we're having now came out of
actors dealing with fears or being a
problem and if you're pushing up against
an actor and they're a problem and you
have a problem with an actor
and they're being resistant or being
with withholding or whatever if you keep
pushing up against that problem and keep
pushing it'll probably get stronger and
so the thing is make a shift
interrogation is one way to make a shift
going for a walk with the actor maybe
the ship say let's go let's get out
let's get out of here let's get off the
set I'm Elise possibly shooting yeah but
I'm the director guess well I read
everybody does what I want to do I've
done this let's go for a walk where are
we going I don't know you want to get a
cup of coffee and suddenly they're going
okay that's a shift let's approach this
in a different way take the pressure off
can you do something differently rather
than just pushing against it
you